yes why I'm with the amazing Gary
Vaynerchuk CEO has a senior media among
other things many other things thank you
how's it going it's going really well
it's great to be here yeah I attend
South by so it's changed quite a bit
when we used to do things like this it
would be on like a small flip cam now
there's very expensive cameras and rigs
and lighting and a lot has changed a lot
the same but I'm very happy to be here
hello everybody that's in this room
thrilled to spend some time together
awesome alright so you're always part of
the trends you're forecasting what's the
thing we're talking about this year
what's exciting you you know I mean I
don't think you know listen the fact the
matter is nine years ago Twitter
exploded here and then all of a sudden
South by how to be this place where
things got launched the reality is
really besides Twitter and Foursquare
nothing has ever been launched here
right so like this is an opening for you
I don't you know but I mean but I mean I
think like this notion of like what's
exciting the same stuff that's always
been exciting which is I'm not super
worried about features or what what's
getting covered the most vital media I'm
worried about where consumer attention
is and how do I story tell natively to
that platform in that environment so
things that I'm not excited about our
consumer VR I do not think consumer VR
is here next week I think we especially
if you're at South buying this lounge
we're excited about it we understand
that technology is there it's you know
it's exciting but the day when an
American or a human being spends 3-4
hours a day in contact lenses and lives
in a virtual world is much further away
than the people that are in that
industry wish it to be the things that
excite me is that Facebook ads are
underpriced and Instagram and snapchat
influencers are under underpriced and
most people just have opinions about it
even very bright people in this room and
the people watching at home and there
are very few practitioners in March 2017
marketing and that's what excites me
because when you have a lack of
practitioner ship there's a ability to
exploit those opportunities if you're
deeply grounded in those principle
funny because some people actually think
there was a bubble anyway it is always
going to be those case studies or
there's what bubbles is well if I get
you points their marketing bubble
influencer marketing has even started
even though it's a 1 2 to 3 best on
people's best guess is billion-dollar
market the reality is is that influencer
marketing has always been here like
right like John Wayne smoked Lucky
Strikes like we somebody were paying
attention to doing something with a
brand is tried and true
it's just that Instagram and snapchat
and Facebook and these platforms are at
such scale of distribution now and
there's no middleman NBC and Comcast
used to get the middle price now the
platform is the distribution and the end
user is getting those economics directly
with the brand so we're living through
just the early stages of that genre
because that's just tried-and-true like
that just always has been here it just
looks a little bit different than we saw
it 40 years ago now you're an influencer
you could say but you're also a CEO
you're an entrepreneur you're
businessman how do you balance between
your own personal brand and then you
know be responsible to a company and
employees and all that I run my company
on this video of an 800% hundred thirty
million dollar year business and that
takes up all my time the garyvee thing
is my side hustle I have a team that
records content in vlog form we write
here even early rocky just travel with
you yes the rock is the person I love
the most
d-roc is with me all the time and it's
my hack I figured it out d-roc films we
make a vlog in that we have 18 hours
worth of content that's happening a lot
of those turn into my medium posts a lot
of those turn into my meme videos a lot
of those turn into my audio podcast I
don't have time to build a personal
brand but I don't time I live my life as
an entrepreneur and I don't win on being
attractive or funny I went on being an
operator and being write about things
that are happening and that's just my
day-to-day life and then we produce it
at home but I spend all my time running
my company when I do public speaking
that's business development for
vaynermedia it's a lot more fun to get a
three million dollar scope doing a
keynote at the AAA than being part of an
RF
process that's a smart business yeah so
I look I think being an influencer first
of all 99% of people that say they're an
influencer in their Instagram account
are full of [ __ ] and for the one without
that on your Instagram account like I'm
an influencer many do and then and then
and then I think the ones that like
being an influencer means that you're
bringing value to people as a person
living and creating content through
these platforms that people are paying
attention to and so you've got to have a
lot of talent to actually win that for
you know for every Logan Paul who I see
in the background there are eight
thousand eighty thousand eight hundred
thousand people that aspire to make
videos and pictures on Instagram and
make a living out of it and the reality
is they're not interesting enough or
smart enough or talented enough so it's
just supply and demand of are you able
to have somebody's attention and what is
the one supposed to do if they don't
have a person to run around following
them on a camera do what I did for the
first thirty years of my life build a
business that allows you to afford one
you know like I look I think this sure
like I think a lot of people forget
about my narrative because of my spiel
in this in this genre I spent the first
15 16 years of my life building an
actual wine retail business before I
even said one word to the world about my
business thoughts I didn't come out the
womb and say I'm an influencer I built
an actual business and I talked about
building businesses and it was that the
platforms weren't there yet right it
probably helped me in some ways because
but yeah because they weren't there and
by the way they were there so a lot of
people here there's a lot of OGS in here
blogging was very real in 2002 3 4 I
passed on that because I'm not good at
writing and if you can't write you're
not going to be successful and blogging
and so the thing I tell everybody in
this room and people watching at home
like self-awareness is a big part of
this as well you have to know what
you're good at and what you're not good
at the amount of people that have
started video shows because they hear
video marketing is good but they're
scared to be in front of a camera and
they're awkward that's just not a good
strategy it's not your normal place like
you have to know yourself and so even
though the mediums were there I could
have been a blogger I just knew that I
couldn't communicate very effectively in
the writing format and so I punted it
kept building a business and
then when short-form Twitter when video
for YouTube came out I'm like that I
think I tend to and that's what I jumped
into you talk about hospital all the
time right and so what our point in the
hustle if it's just not working do you
say maybe I need to move in another
direction that's hard you know I wanted
to tell somebody that to quit off of
their dream or what they want to do is
very difficult because the reality is it
could have been the next day that
something good could have happened and
you just jumped off at the same token I
equated to American Idol
you know rehearsals where people really
think they're great at singing and they
suck [ __ ] I think that um there's a lot
of people who think if they just keep
doing it they're going to break out and
be a micro celebrity and they're not
going to because they don't have the
talent I think it's a very personal
answer sure I don't think I have the
answer even if I really know somebody
it's a very difficult one that's one
that I don't think I'm in a position to
turn on Gary does not happen answer I
don't I don't answer most things I think
you know for people that follow me I say
very narrow very deep in my lanes I
don't know most things what I do know is
attention of end consumer what I do know
is what you're up to what you're not
going to do and what you're going to do
and that's what I trade on and that's a
good place to play speaking of that what
are people doing now what are people
wanting what what does everyone have to
take notice of now we're pretty plain I
mean this is not a this is a mobile only
world in my opinion and here's what I
mean by that when I trade attention
nothing's dead billboards aren't dead
radio is not dead
television consumption is not dead it's
the advertising behind them that you
want to drive your business results that
needs to be debated what overpriced and
what's under priced I think the
number-one bet in marketing today is
buying a Superbowl commercial I think it
is the number-one deal in the world
I think it's grossly underpriced every
person in here will know the thirty
second story of that brand whether they
watch it on YouTube or during the
Superbowl and it's an incredible bargain
at the same token I think the number one
worse deal in marketing today is buying
programmatic banner and pre-roll ads on
the exchanges and justifying digital
spend on CPM costs because nobody in
here is paying attention to them and we
pouring ungodly amounts of money to it
so that you would say wait a minute are
you not a digital she's a traditionalist
I'm not I'm going very narrow I think I
Heart Radio live read radio ads by the
jockey who's running that station is an
incredible bargain radio meanwhile I
think I think that back to television I
think the Oscars are the most overpriced
added two billion two million dollars a
spot because we want that as marketers
to be the Superbowl but it's not the
sport of watching commercials during the
Oscars is nowhere close to the sport of
watching commercials during the
Superbowl so ah for me it's mobile only
mobile is the only place where there's
true besides Super Bowl underpriced
attention you've got to be very narrow
within that I'm obsessed I think I think
everybody in here will regret not
spending more money on Facebook Ads
during this period because the average
six to fourteen dollar CPMs that you see
today are going to be fifty sixty
seventy dollars and four to five years
and everybody's going to cry but there's
people that think Facebook ads are over
right now that that are just
non-practitioners I mean this is back to
my opening line there are people in this
room that have opinions on VR on AI an
Alexa voice on snapchat ads on Facebook
guys and they've never executed in those
environments
I think it's massively important to be
the architect and to be the plumber and
to be the Mason and I think that's
what's lacking Shira and I something
I've always relied on which is I'm
trying to be strategic but I'm executing
my [ __ ] daily biggest reason I build a
personal brand is so I use Instagram
snapchat musically Facebook Twitter
every day every feature every time it
keeps me a strong strategist because I'm
in my [ __ ] not pontificating on
TechCrunch there you go that deserves an
applause come on so what platforms are
you excited about right now I mean you
are a jerk
yeah Facebook I'm heavily excited about
Facebook I'm excited about snapchat
because everybody thinks that it's over
because Instagram stories and yet
there's tons of attention there and the
marketplace to buy filters there is five
dollars an hour for 20,000 square feet
if you're smart market or buying filters
on the open market placing snapchat
right now could be remarkable if you
care to sell to people under 35 years
old influencers on those
two platforms I Heart Radio weirdly
enough why breed by the jockey not the
ads in the radio Radio Network no no no
no no hurry I Heart Radio no let's go
more specific when the jockey that runs
the station live reads like these are
the nuances that I watch and I watch
them for people in the room not on
internal modeling mixes that justify
spend behavior in Fortune 500 companies
but based on actual transaction data if
stuff is actually selling if donations
are actually being made it's another
important part that we should be
spending more time on where there are
people that literally justify behavior
based on views and likes and following
count and that is just that lagging is
that's my engagement sale sale selling
[ __ ] Shira yeah you want to make money
well yes I want to make money and
anybody who's getting paid to help a
business wants to make money like
Comcast wants to sign people [ __ ] up
like they're not there to like feel good
about themselves like this is [ __ ]
business what the [ __ ] is everybody
talking about yeah I mean you a
capitalist it'd be you know hit me I
listen I love hippies but like like but
like the fact that matter is you you
know the reality is is if you're talking
about business you're talking about
business if you're talking about raising
money for the PTA that's your goal
everybody has a goal running for office
bringing awareness to the family that
live next door to you who's house burned
down you can go very noble you can go
very vain having more fans you could be
whatever you want but the one thing that
ties every person in this room with is
that we're all fighting for the
attention of the end user before you
tell me how great your services and why
yours is better than Amazon's or your
sneakers cooler than adidas is you need
my attention and we are pouring hundreds
of billions of dollars into places that
no longer have the attention right so it
lastly we're wrapping this up okay
advice for people that are starting new
companies they can't be buying tons on
Facebook or boosting how are people
succeeded Missy an age with now big
publisher coming in playing its harder
you know first and foremost patients
startups lack patients like everybody
wants everything tomorrow like it's
going to take three four five six years
of you working 8 9 10 15 hours a day
before something interesting can
happen like just because you want to be
an influencer and snowboarding nobody
else wants you to be so first and
foremost you have to actually have
talent that's another thing like if your
startup your product has to be good let
me promise everybody in this room I know
a lot of people in this room the
greatest marketing of all time if I if
I'm lucky enough to produce the greatest
marketing campaign and execution of all
time if the product that that marketing
is deployed against is [ __ ] you've lost
so your first of all your startup has to
be good is it valuable like if you're
just starting are you bringing value
second you have to persevere and produce
an or you know lucky small companies are
now we have distribution we have like be
a practitioner know that when you post a
piece of content I so many people come
up to me and say Gary it's so hard I
look at their Instagram and they're not
posting any of their content with
hashtags which is a by accident way to
pick up exposure in a world where they
have no money when you have no money
when I took over my dad's business it
did three million dollars a year ten
percent gross profit three hundred
thousand dollars before expenses my
first year marketing budget was fourteen
thousand dollars when you have no money
and I built that business from a three
to a sixty million dollar business in
five years I had to make every penny
perfect so I was right about email
marketing in ninety six and I was right
and because of that I had ninety one
percent open rates when Google AdWords
came out the day it came out I paid five
cents a click for words before anybody
bid me up and I was super right and that
worked it was that last verse of
preparation and you ever get anything
wrong what do you do like any come in I
I give everything wrong it's just that I
can't recall it because once it's wrong
I'm moving on to the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you [ __ ]
up on is the quickest way for the next
thing not to work right yeah so like so
I think I do everything I mean you know
this this is a fun thing to say some
people in the back noticed I was a
breakout YouTube star in the first year
2006 I decided that the right strategy
was to leave YouTube completely and go
to viddler because viddler offered me
equity in their company and I've left an
enormous amount of attention ID me ated
from my intention thesis to do
short-term economics and equity in a
company and I lost I lost Wendy brought
finally came in my life two years ago we
started to try to build up my youtube
for the first time
I was sitting on 40,000 users followers
in a world record I've had millions if I
just stayed the course so I make
mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
[ __ ] about my mistakes everybody else
cares about your mistakes if you're
worried about your own mistakes you've
already lost that's awesome thank you
you're welcome Carrie it's a great way
for us to leave it off so amazing you're
on Facebook
Carrie zerbies during this video on page
oh yeah well we're doing all different
closing this up and creating four more
right here at from my free book and 50
but oh and where is the books online if
you are watching no I don't want to
chill but for you guys your book google
it
[Music]
you